[Music]
melissa is with us in seattle hi melissa
welcome to the ramsay show
thank you very much
hey what's up um
i had a question on what we should do
first um so we have everything paid off
besides my car which we owe about 10 000
on which we should have paid off within
the next six months
and then my student loan which is
massive oh it's massive to me
and
so i'm a stay-at-home mom and my
husband's an electrician and so he works
for the union where even though he
personally has an experience they do
come in these periods where sometimes
they don't have work
for periods of time
so my question with that is
should we save after we pay off the car
should we save towards that 10 000 in
case something like that happens
or should i just knock out the student
loan debt
[Music]
what's your degree in
health information management
how many kids have you got
four
got a house full
what ages
one to thirteen
wow whoa
you are a busy lady
okay
um what does he make
um all together
met
with um the va benefits that he also has
we get about 90 000
90
yes okay and how much is your massive
student loan
80
80.
okay
all right with a ten thousand dollar
card debt that means you need ninety
thousand making ninety thousand to be
debt free
with four kids and we have a son who's
uh in going to private school to which
we were kind of cornered into
because of the washington state laws
that have been passed recently
i'm not aware of what you're talking
about
um um
basically we did not we were kind of
cornered into putting him in private
school
um because we felt that
the public school district has become
very unhealthy teaching kids they should
not be teaching
and my son was being bullied as well at
school um because he's a christian
okay
and how much does probably how much does
private school cost
under a little bit under 8 000.
okay
all right so if we said uh 30 000 a year
that'd be pretty aggressive in your
situation in debt reduction you'd be
debt free in three years
okay
the more unstable your husband's job is
the more you would push pause on all of
this and pile up cash
but i don't think it's that unstable i
think it's just unpredictable
yes and the maltese hasn't worked since
he started a couple years ago was two
weeks
yeah but then they're in the history of
the union there was guys who didn't work
like in 2008 where they didn't work for
a year
yeah in which case you'd go get another
job yeah melissa i'm curious about this
too
have you guys sat down and discussed
union versus not union electrician
opportunities for him even in the state
of washington
um his union there he will not make what
he makes where he um where he is at i
mean the they make over 60 an hour free
insurance um our union the employers pay
the insurance great pension
there's no one that's going to touch
what he makes okay all right
has he actually shot it or is that just
what the union told him
no that um so right now he's an
apprentice so he's getting a percentage
of that
but once he is licensed in two years he
will be making that and that is what
they make for everybody
and
yet we get
great insurance that's completely
employer paid
um
he's not gonna
and they're one of the best in
washington yeah how open is he to doing
uh side work as well whether it be
electrician work or any other kind of
handiwork because he's got more talents
than just electrician
yes and actually we used to own our own
construction business is that but i know
he's been trying to work a lot of
saturdays as much as he can good um
and he is okay doing side work um he
can't do it with being an electrician
because it's again salon washington okay
like how long has he been uh how long
has he been out of work what's the
longest he has been out of work
two weeks
and how long ago was that
last november okay
all right
and you can't eat on a thousand dollars
in two weeks
yes you can
okay so i'm going to say i'm going to
stick with the baby steps and i'm going
to put you on a scorched earth budget
and he's going to pick up all the extra
he can work you got a thousand dollars
in the bank in case he's off for two
weeks or in case some other little thing
comes up two weeks is not gonna kill you
and um you're not gonna be out of food
everything's gonna be okay and um if you
see a long layoff coming he needs to
change jobs
because because your family can't afford
for him to have a long layoff
and then in the midst of that you guys
start really beating the snot out of
this debt and i want you debt free in
three years a hundred percent debt-free
in three years that's just that's the
schedule that's 2500 bucks a month for
three years
and you can do this but i'm telling you
you got your hands full with four kids
you got a lot of stuff coming at you
right now a lot of different issues that
you outlined in this call and uh so
there's a certain amount of grown-up
stress with what you're dealing with
and i think you can do it though i
really think you can do it and it's what
i would do if i were in your shoes
because i think the best life for you
three years from today is to do what i
just said versus something else
and uh i mean you can have a polycash
sitting there if you want uh it's not
what we teach
and the only way i would teach apollo
cash sitting there is if you have a a
high probability that you're getting
ready to lose your job in which case you
need to change directions
on the
union versus non-union direction
uh because i can promise you that
there's a there's a housing boom in
seattle
and uh you can get a job as an
electrician
and um
you're pretty much feeding me the union
line back
yeah when we're asking you about this
yeah good insurance good insurance good
insurance sixty dollars an hour you
can't make it anywhere else only he
doesn't make sixty dollars an hour and
he doesn't average that if he gets laid
off for six months
so um i'm not i'm not anti-union but you
just can't you know you gotta you gotta
assess the entire opportunity here
compared to being non-union and then
decide which one i'm okay if he wants to
stay union but you can't you can't have
it both ways you can't go oh it's
completely unstable i'm freaked out but
it's the best job in the world right and
let's be very clear a qualified
electrician that is in a non-union
situation can eat all he wants to eat it
is an all-you-can-eat buffet right now
out there as far as work goes so i would
i don't know that you can't make more
than 60 an hour if i was trying to get
out of debt and i was an electrician
i mean you can make up some ground right
now and that's not going anywhere
absolutely